we switch gears now to a powerful winter
storm in the West it is still causing
nightmare journeys for some people in
the middle of the very busy travel time
the system is now blowing across the
Southwest after dumping torrential rain
and heavy snow on Southern California
the mountains just outside Los Angeles
got up to 3 feet of snow and that is
where Jamie yuccas is now in Castaic
which is about 40 miles north of LA so
Jamie what are you seeing well Vlad I
want to show you this is i-5 and you can
see that it is shut down right now it's
been shut down for the past 30 hours
it's the main connector between Southern
California and Northern California we've
seen a number of cars and even semi
trucks having to turn around in this
spot and go back and wait this out
there's no word on when it will reopen
at this point either so that's the
situation here but now this storm is
barreling towards Nevada and Arizona
before heading further east less than 30
miles northwest of Las Vegas
snow is blanketing Mount Charleston
creating hazardous conditions for
visitors from Sin City normally I'll
take us maybe 30 minutes took us about
an hour today just go to flow following
people travelers heading from Nevada to
California sat in traffic for hours
after snowy conditions forced the
closure of the busy interstate 15
alternate routes were overwhelmed as
well I've turned around twice I came
over the pass to go to work and because
of weather we didn't work so trying to
get back home the storm wreaked havoc in
Southern California yesterday with snow
in the mountains closing two of the
state's major interstates diverting
traffic and leaving travelers frustrated
like this any signage is just suddenly
everybody's getting off of here and
there's no instruction on what to do
some drivers stuck in the snow posting
video of the mess to social media if
you've been stuck out here actually for
about almost five hours in San Diego
heavy rain shut down roads submerging
cars
and it wasn't just ground travel that
was affected long lines were seen at
airports across the West including here
at sea-tac airport in Seattle now
depending on when you're located in the
country you may either say rain ice or
snow the planes are gonna see plenty of
rain but places like Colorado and New
Mexico that snows going to come down
very quickly
we're told a foot to two feet of snow is
possible in the Rockies data alright
Jamie the spirit of the season nobody
seems to want right now thank you
you